il se passe quelque chose de spécial à
granby ces jours ci et c'est bien plus
que l'esprit des fêtes qui s'installe il
y à un élan de solidarité sans précédent
le salut bonjour comment puis-je vous
aider ça va être vraiment accompagner
des gens pour les bénévoles se
manifestent avec un sentiment d'urgence
à la hauteur des besoins
on est vendue à une liste de 50
personnes qui veulent aider les céréales
joan où elle est et son équipe ont tout
organisé
l'école la garderie les papiers tout
pour accueillir et fournir le nécessaire
à 70,6 rien qui ne connaissent personne
au canada et qui dès leur arrivée auront
droit à l'aide sociale
le temps trouver du travail tels nous à
s'organiser pour avoir un logement
adéquat pour que la personne plus un peu
se nourrir puis un peu avoir reste de
ces choses pour vivre elle attend
impatiemment les premières familles qui
devrait atterrir à tout moment on voit
les accueillir ici puis on va aller les
mener dans leur appartement
le soir même oui vous souriez
oui j'ai hâte
pourquoi avoir choisi cet appartement
c'est en demeure mais plus beaux
appartements il ya un très très belle
vue mais dit il suffit et propriétaire
d'un immeuble à logements il sait
exactement ce que c'est que d'atterrir
dans l'inconnu il a fui son coût sauve
natale
j'écoutais le mans je sais qu'elle
stocke et larry cinq ans bref ma perdu
et c'est pourquoi il est réservé trois
appartements pour des familles syriennes
qui comme lui devront rebâtir leur vie
je travaillais beaucoup vraiment
beaucoup
les messages pour tout les nouveaux
arrivants j'aimerais bien dire aux
autres aussi les morales et puis pensées
positives et vous êtes dans une terre
d'accueil et des possibilités au canada
elle imagine déjà une grande famille ici
des enfants la vie et le reste juste à
avoir des meubles versa je sais que
c'est aussi parce qu'il l'a vécue que le
simple citoyen peut faire toute la
différence
tout le monde va acheter des meubles de
sa part question c'est moralement
moralement retard avec eux
jean luc p très justement devenu un
modèle dans la communauté à granby
pour ce qui est de l'accompagnement des
réfugiés le jumelage pour moi là c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas compliqué ça
ne coûte rien c'est ça coûte quelque
chose oui matin son concept est tout
simple il applique depuis des années
s'est jumelée à une famille de réfugiés
pour au moins un an
être là pour eux dès qu'ils mettent les
pieds dans leur nouvel environnement
pour la première fois à l'eau on a
quelqu'un qui vont en faire
l'interprétation de nos propos ok entre
les deux familles et concrètement ça
veut dire que le lendemain lorsque je
vais aller chez eux les voir on voit que
je comprends je vais avoir un outil
informatique avec google images gogo
vidéo google traduction
mes mains mon visage et on va
communiquer comme ça c'est ça
concrètement il son modèle a fait du
chemin
cent soixante dix familles de la région
se sont offertes pour guider des
réfugiés syriens
serge courtemanche un jeune retraité qui
a du temps c'est inscrit sans hésiter et
garde son père souffre un peu moins de
facilité dans son l'heure toujours leur
atterrissage à granby et comme bien
d'autres il est prêt à recevoir une
famille syrienne à la maison pour fêter
le réveillon
pourquoi ne serait pas de faire en sorte
que eux aussi peu goûté à une forme de
sérénité de ses graduelle même sérénité
donc franchement on vraiment bien besoin
peut-être que dans six mois je disais
mais finalement ça reste est pourtant
fait comme ça que ça s'est passé ça a
été j'ai eu des moments plus difficiles
je m'y attends mais bon vous êtes là ça
pour ça je suis à 100% mais dit il
suffit aussi c'est sûr que oui et que
oui je vais faire le même trajet
qu'est ce qu'est le monde de granby ont
fait pas mal et ses yeux brillent quand
il parle de la rue principale de la
montagne du lac telles qu'il les a
découvert un jour d'automne il y à 16